[Music]
hello and welcome to the week in 60
minutes brought to you by spectator tv
and broadcast on thursday the 7th of
april i'm kate andrews the spectators
economics editor and your host this week
on this week's show
russia has withdrawn forces from the
north of ukraine to focus its offensive
on the east of the country we'll get the
latest with the historian anthony beaver
and writer james meek
it comes as pictures emerged of a mass
grave in bucha 20 kilometers to the
north of kiev fraser nelson writes this
week's cover piece on the politics of
war crimes and he'll join us on the show
after 15 years in power what is the
snp's record in scotland james heal and
michael simmons write this week about
the quote poor planning willful waste
and absence of accountability end quote
that have characterized their time and
power we'll speak to james as well as
jackie bailly deputy leader of scottish
labour
number 10 has gone through multiple
rounds of staffing since boris johnson
became prime minister what is the
current face of number 10. katie balls
writes the politics column in this
week's magazine and she'll join me on
the show
and finally paul wood writes in this
week's magazine about the fate of
belarusian president alexander lukshenko
and how it depends on the war in ukraine
he'll join me to explain
but before we get going a reminder to
subscribe to the spectator magazine you
get 12 issues of the magazine for just
12 pounds and a free 20 pound amazon
voucher too just go to spectator dot co
dot uk forward slash tv offer
and why not subscribe to our youtube
channel too just click the red subscribe
button at the bottom of this video and
tap the bell icon to make sure you never
miss an episode
russian forces have withdrawn from the
north of ukraine after suffering heavy
defeats in the area around kiev i'm
joined now by sir anthony beaver a
military historian and the author of
stalingrad and james meek a contributing
editor at the london review of books who
has reported on conflicts in eastern
europe and the middle east
anthony james thanks for joining us
james we've seen the collapse of the
russian invasion in the north of ukraine
what's next
well
it's widely assumed that what's next is
a renewed assault on
uh
ukrainian positions in eastern ukraine
when the invasion began the strongest
part of the ukrainian army was based in
the east
in that part of the eastern donbass
region which uh russia and its um its
local proxy forces had not managed to
uh had not managed to conquer and at the
outset of the war
it was one of the stated war aims of
russia to
conquer the whole of the donbass not
simply those those parts that
that they already had but to take
control of the entire region
so
if russia was able to
to sweep back
those very very heavily entrenched
ukrainian forces
from the rest of the donbass they could
have the beginnings of something that
they could call a victory
in time for um time for victory day on
on may the 9th
but of course there are many many
complications to that
one is now that the russians have
withdrawn from the north of ukraine the
ukrainians have forces free to shore up
their positions in in the donbass
the other is that simply can the
russians do it do they have the the
forces do they have the um
the the men do they have the equipment
to uh
to break down this extremely stubborn
ukrainian resistance given that it has
been well over a month now that they
have been trying to uh subjugate a
single city mariupol in the south of the
donbass and they haven't yet managed to
do that
um there are a whole
series of of cities in the donbass that
the ukrainians currently hold they're
well dug in
and it will not be easy and it will not
be fast for the uh the russians to
conquer them the second
massive issue um is that in the course
of their invasion
the russians have
conquered other
large areas of southern ukraine between
crimea
and andombas that's partly the donbass
region but also the south of zapparuji
region a very very large uh nuclear
civilian nuclear power plant in
zapparojee which is still under russian
control
and most um complex of all uh hersone
region
which is in the very west of this area
that we're talking about um and i think
if um
we're looking at some kind of future
armistice perhaps um along the uh korean
model
which clearly would be very
unsatisfactory to the ukrainians and in
some ways to the russians but it's a
possible way forward i think it's it's
that area of uncertainty as to what it
is that russia wants and what it is that
ukraine can um can regain in in that
area of of the southwest um in the kind
of the approaches to edessa that um
that that causes a lot of problems but
but briefly um and without going into
all these details of of strategy and
tactics and geography i think what we
can look forward to in the next few
weeks is is much more blood and toil
and and slaughter and um
hideous unnecessary waste of life and uh
and human capital i want to come on to
the aspect of war crimes in a bit but
first anthony you've said that putin is
quote militarily locked in the past end
quote can you expand on this and are you
surprised at his army's collapse in the
north
i'm not entirely surprised i think we
tended to underestimate the degree of
corruption within the russian military
putin's russia is not the soviet union
and putin's army is not certainly not
the red army
and what we saw was an extraordinary
repetition of the mistakes which
actually the red army had made itself in
the second world war and a lot of this
comes from putin's uh distorted uh
obsession
with the second world war
the way that they sent their tanks scene
in a straight line without infantry
support in those first few days
when uh it appeared and i think it was
sort of part of the original plan uh was
really to split uh ukraine down the
middle along the line of the nipper um
and they were even uh russian tank
troops were even adding bedsteads and
other things uh to the top of their
tanks hoping that that would perform a
provoke
early explosions of premature explosions
of anti-tank rockets well this was
exactly what they'd done in 1945
attacking into berlin
uh he'd also prepared the troops with
ideas that they would be greeted as
liberators well there we have 1968 and
what happened in prague when the water
packed forces arrived and
they found themselves being spat out and
cursed by the checks
um
this obsession with the past certainly
does seem to have uh affected uh tactics
uh what they are also i think trying to
do adding on to what james has just been
saying uh i think the great hope was uh
this
attack down the center down the line of
the nipper uh was also going to lead to
a massive envelopment
of the ukrainian forces in eastern
ukraine facing facing the donbass um but
i think that the uh collapse of this
particular uh axis of advance uh has now
gone far enough and i think therefore uh
the russians um
chances of really uh achieving the sort
of decisive victory that they hoped for
has rather disappeared
much
will of course depend
on how morale holds up uh i think there
have been over-optimistic reports in the
western press that there is an imminent
collapse of the whole of the
russian army uh so far they haven't been
bringing in blocking troops or blocking
groups as they had as stalin did in 1942
but there is no doubt that they will be
uh using much more severe um much more
severe uh sanctions against their own
troops with probably shooting deserters
and so forth what was becoming
increasingly clear is that putin is as
pitiless towards his own uh people as he
is towards ukrainians
as we saw with the preparations for
dealing with bodies uh the mobile
crematorium brought in
and the whole question of the disposal
of bodies
in
their own troops in uh in ukraine and i
think that that is producing a great
deal of anger within the army but also
spreading to uh the civilian population
but that does not mean that you know
there will be a uh a palace coup against
putin or anything like that i think
that's being uh far too optimistic but
i'm sure we'll be going on to that in a
moment anthony on that point what is the
current state of ukraine's resistance
right now and how effective do you think
it will be encountering a deployed
russia in the east
i think the state of ukrainian
resistance has been most impressive
um
i think that they were um they managed
to get in some vital training just in
time uh i think that the british
training teams uh out there did an
incredible job with the end laws and all
the rest of it
um and there's no doubt about the state
of morale i think it's it's shaken the
russians it's uh it's even perhaps
shaken ukrainians themselves and how
well they have performed
um there have been some very clever
tactics used use of drones and uh
other
original areas and this again is a
an example of how putin has not learned
from for example the effect of tanks
there is putin uh as i say
obsessed with the second world war where
the tank was a symbol of power and
strength uh almost invincible but um uh
we see the tanks being taken out again
and again and in many long lines and he
had did not learn the lessons either
from libya or nagorno-karabakh in the
fighting between the armenians and
azerbaijanis
and that actually war has changed and
also the russian army has not learned
how to uh engage in urban warfare and
not as a way that the allies did in iraq
for example with raqqa and so forth by
cordoning off sectors of a city
surrounding it corning off sectors and
doing it in a progressive way all
they've done is they've tried to charge
in if that didn't work um and then they
resorted to artillery thermobaric uh
weapons and uh just general general
destruction so there's very little uh
shall we say modern
thinking uh on urban warfare going on at
the moment in the russian army and that
is perhaps one of the reasons why
they've lost so many senior officers
james last question to you
obviously what we're discovering in
ukraine evidence of these war crimes
makes it much harder to engage in peace
negotiations if a peace agreement were
found between russia and ukraine what's
the likelihood that putin would stick to
it
he uh he has shown himself not to be a
very um trustworthy individual
and um i mean i i think
the striking thing about these um these
were these these these crimes that we
are now seeing i mean i would argue that
the entire war is a crime
um and these um horrific um episodes of
of um
killing civilians and torturing
civilians are only one part of the of
the overall crime of of the war but
how can we possibly be surprised um
at what
this regime in russia has done um
not just after what happened in syria
but after what putin did in
in chechnya um i mean it was such a
clear forerunner of the attitude of the
man namely here is chechnya an
indivisible part of russia which must be
russian
and therefore
it must be utterly and mercilessly
raised to the ground um in order that
this place which we love so much um
should be returned to us it's that that
mixture of of a demand
um for
um essential um
blood relatives to be reunited with the
um with the murder of these blood
relatives that that we saw in 2000 um
and yet between then and now 22 years
have passed um and there has been so
much accommodation with this man um from
um not just from the obvious suspects of
of of donald trump and nigel farage and
alex salmon but from british petroleum
and shell and all the vast um
cash
handling um
enterprises of the of the city of london
so this is not
a new situation um
and as far as the peace talks are
concerned um it is going to be a very
bitter spill to swallow um
this um is
a slobber now milosevic figure that we
are negotiating
with and um
we cannot realistically expect that he
is going to be in the dock of the hague
because russia is
um
one of the um the biggest nuclear powers
on the planet and um putin is
um unless somebody has some brilliant
suggestion or unless there is this
extremely unlikely palace coup he is um
virtually immune from that kind of that
kind of reach so some kind of deal is is
going to have to be made
and i think
the least unpalatable version and it is
going to be unpalatable whatever happens
is
the maximum
degree of ukrainian military success
which will almost certainly not be
the complete recapture of all lost
ukrainian territory from 2014.
the maximum possible degree of ukrainian
military success
and armistice
along korean lines
or a piece along
cyprus lines
where the war is not over there is no
peace treaty but the fighting has
stopped
and a clear line
is drawn between the two sides i think
the absolutely crucial thing after a
line
is is drawn
um hopefully with as much of ukraine
intact as as as possible after that line
is drawn what is the west going to do
to protect
that line because
i do not feel that um a simple piece of
paper is is enough and i think that's
where the trust in putin becomes
extremely problematic there will need to
be a peace deal there will need to be
negotiations with putin but if they are
not backed up by something more than a
piece of paper to stop the russians when
they have paused had another think um
built up their army again from simply
going back in for another go
um
i i think we're going to need more than
uh
than a treaty for that
anthony and james thanks for joining
spectator tv
so if russia has committed war crimes in
ukraine can putin and his army be
prosecuted for them can we really expect
to see them in the docks
fraser nelson the spectator's editor
writes this week's cover story about the
politics of war crimes and he joins the
show now
fraser thanks for joining me you write
in this week's cover piece that the mass
grave ambucha represented the kind of
barbarism that europe thought it had
left behind in the last century
what was your reaction when you saw the
atrocities coming out of ukraine and
what's been the reaction of western
governments
well these these pictures of the dead
bodies of children of mutilated corpses
of civilians were as sickening as
anything that i've seen in my lifetime
certainly in this continent and and it
brought back to mind actually an old
quote in john buckin about how we like
to think that we're so civilized
but it's the the divide between our
civilized life and the reign of saturn
is very very thin it's a sheet of glass
a tap here a tap there and we descend
into barbarism now it's just amazing how
quickly that happened in the first world
war the second world war and now we're
seeing it happening again in front of
our eyes
what is strange here is that we're now
watching it in real time we're watching
it just a few hours flight here from
from london and it is being documented
by western satellites when the russians
tried to make out that these figures
these images were fake we were able to
say very quickly no they weren't because
here the satellite images taken just a
few days ago and yet there's a strange
feeling of impotence because we all know
that if we were to go and confront
russia directly if we descend in the
british military or impose one of these
no-fly zones that would mean war with a
nuclear power a far wider conflagration
than potentially far more deaths so
there is a feeling of horror of
disbelief
i guess it challenges your notion of
history and progress i mean it's funny
to think that you would ever live to see
these these scenes again but they're
happening now and they could get worse i
guess that gives the question for a lot
of people what if anything can be done
president biden has received some
criticism for saying that putin is a war
criminal do you think that language is
helpful
no it's not helpful for quite a big
reason to be accused of war crimes is
quite important if you're an accused war
criminal then you can never leave your
country you could be arrested anywhere
where interpol can put out a warrant and
there is a logic and warfare for
allowing the the bad guy a ticket out a
bridge where he can retreat over if he
wants
so if you were to indict putin for war
crimes you would basically be saying to
him that there's no way out for him not
in his lifetime the argument is that
might encourage somebody like putin to
fight on to the last rather than cut his
losses and withdraw that's why boris
johnson for example has been saying to
russians in the video this week that
your president has been accused of war
crime boris is quite careful not to make
that accusation himself and even biden's
officials have said that he misspoke
that he is not personally accusing putin
of war crimes he just thinks there
should be a war crimes trial which it
certainly seems there will be
so if we're not going to be sending
boots to the ground of ukraine and we're
not going to be calling putin a war
criminal we're going to be careful with
our language
what realistically can western
governments do about any of this more
sanctions i mean there's they're coming
uh they're being implemented but so far
sanctions don't seem to have stopped
putin's atrocities and hasn't seemed to
stop the russian soldiers from um
increasing evidence now that they have
been torturing raping and killing
innocent civilians
well there are things we can do we can
increase the sanctions right now we're
still or europe is still buying about
half a billion dollars of oil a day from
russia that could be cut down although
it would be painful and britain and
other countries can send a higher grade
of weapons to the ukrainians to help
them not just defend their territory but
to take the fight to the russians in the
occupied parts of ukraine and try and
push them out
but i do think that the war crimes
agenda can also help if you document
these things in real time we're talking
not just the videos like the landscape
show to the united nations but forensic
evidence and then you can start to name
the guilty russians the ukrainians are
a few weeks perhaps months most away
from from doing that certainly issuing
their own indictments for their own
courts then you can send a message
certainly to people around putin that
what he's doing here is an act of
barbarism and it is the kind of um
it will go down not like georgia not the
crimea these those were relatively
straightforward conflicts this will go
down in the annals of human barbarism
and those who are complicit or those who
could have stopped it and didn't will
have a case to answer themselves so i do
think that this helps focus a lot of
people's minds on the sheer barbarism of
what's going on right now it's almost
impossible to write this off as some
kind of border dispute between two
former parts of the soviet empire we've
seen china within india south africa try
their best to be neutral it gets pretty
hard to be neutral when we're seeing
scenes like those at butcher
i was fascinated to read in your piece
how much the british justice department
is doing to help document these war
crimes can you talk us through it yes
well just as britain was one of the
first countries to send arms to ukraine
we did that back in january we've been
one of the first countries to send legal
help as well so right at the start we've
said look if you want help documenting
these war crimes then we can do this
we've got experience of this you need
quite a high caliber of evidence to
prosecute war crime i mean back in
kosovo for example we've had a few bits
of vhs footage not much in syria the
game had changed completely something
like three and a half million videos
have been sent in as evidence of war
crimes and mysterion conflict of those
about half a million not much more have
actually been assessed enough that half
a million barely eight thousand have
been um accepted as admissible evidence
so the amount of
validation you have to do the amount of
documentation you need to do is
absolutely huge and we have offered
british intelligence services whose
communications intercepts helps call out
putin on this way before he actually
invaded ukraine british and american
intelligence were saying this is what
he's going to do and we knew that
because we've got a pretty good line
into what russians are saying to each
other that can be used to help build the
case for prosecution there are other
things britain can do like in legal
clerks we can we're offering to um send
lawyers over to conduct interviews to
make sure the statements are conducted
in a way that would stand muster in an
international court even so15 the unit
of the metropolitan police is being used
to to build evidence they've got they're
right now doing it with rwandan war
crimes um and we are putting that
clerical skill which we built over the
years to bear so right now there's two
parallel investigations there's the
international criminal court in the
hague but ukraine is making its own
domestic case now their chances of
getting defendants are pretty slim but
what they hope to do is to let every
russian know that this in 2022 if you
invade a country what you do can be
intercepted the cameras can come after
you the satellites can come after you
your communications can be on the record
and you can be indicted
and and that indictment can go on the
record you can be named and shamed so
there is no cloak of visibility that
covers you
in war not anymore not in this digital
age
now this might add to push give putin's
generals even some of the soldiers pause
before they they conduct the atrocities
like we saw in butcher i think the
message is going out now but there are
eyes on you there are ears on you and
even if you're covered by your country
you can be named and exposed by digital
means
and yet your sources in the piece are
still telling you that there's a slim to
nothing chance that prosecutions will
happen are we in danger of fooling
ourselves into thinking that this is
going to be successful
after srebrenica we didn't really think
that radhankaravich would be apprehended
but he was he was arrested in 2008 and
right now he's in jail in the isle of
wight people didn't really think that
charles taylor the former president of
liberia would ever be arrested for what
he did in sierra leone but he was and
right now he's in jail in durham so
things the impossible can sometimes
happen although when you're looking at
collapsing states there's a way higher
chance that you would get the
perpetrators there but in a place like
russia even if putin falls he might be
replaced by somebody worse it's hard to
see russia ever
surrender its generals or its former
presidents to an international criminal
court whose authority is not recognized
by the united states let alone russia
itself
so
that actually seeing russians in the
dock is unlikely but then again as the
saying goes the process can be the
punishment if you do see war crime
dossiers being
collated online if every single movement
is done if the forensic evidence is
uploaded then you can show the court of
public opinion the evidence for the
prosecution and you can let all the
invading forces know but the eyes of the
world are on them i do think that serves
a purpose and i during the course of
researching this piece i've become a lot
more persuaded about just how worthwhile
this is i mean yes it's a very expensive
process but war is a very expensive
process i think um shining a light on
war crimes would otherwise go undetected
and certainly unexplored there is a huge
value to that even if there's a scant
chance that you will end up with a
prosecution and a conviction at the end
of it
fraser thanks for joining me
the smp has been in power in hollywood
for 15 years now in this week's magazine
james heal the spectator's diary editor
and michael simmons our data journalist
write that nicholas sturgeon has created
one of the most opaque and centralized
governments in europe
to discuss james joins me now alongside
jackie bailly deputy leader of scottish
labor
james and jackie thanks for joining me
on spectator tv
james you along with our colleague
michael simmons write this week about
the quote poor planning willful waste
and absence of accountability end quote
of the scottish national party over the
past 15 years in power
what in your view has gone so badly
wrong
okay i think a number of things have
gone wrong up in scotland
i think the danger is that secret
government tends to lead to bad
government with a lack of
transparency accountability mechanisms
for some of the failures so those
failures are repeated and exacerbated
and the focal point for this story was
looking at the um ferguson shipyard and
what's gone wrong there and now this is
sort of eight years of delay uh
misspending and the original budget for
these two original vessels has gone from
97 million to 240 million
and so what the real issue is that not
things that have gone wrong but that
these failures have been exacerbated by
a failure to learn from mistakes and the
danger you have with the s p i think is
a party that's been empowered 15 years
now and a tendency to think of itself as
the state and the danger is that any
criticism is seen as somehow treason
and therefore you do not learn from
what's gone wrong previously and um it
just means a failure to learn and that's
why scotland i think is suffering its
public sector outcomes
jack is james being unfair i mean things
go wrong all the time in the public
sector doesn't necessarily mean that
something particularly sinister is going
on
no i think he's perhaps being overly
generous if i could put it that way you
know i've been in the scottish
parliament since 1999 the very beginning
and i have never seen a more
centralizing more secretive government
than the one that's currently in power
um and james is right they simply do not
accept they make mistakes or indeed
learn from them um and what we're
witnessing now is very much a
centralizing command and control
structure that's controlled by nicolas
sturgeon at the very top
dissent is just not allowed debate is
stifled
and the committees of the parliament do
not have teeth they don't seem to be
able to challenge the first minister
because of course the snp majority
votes as one you know we don't have
independent members on committees they
are very much creatures of their own
party if you take the the ferguson
shipyard contract as an example but it
is excessively over budget documents are
missing that would tell us what actually
happened um and it seems to be that key
points in the contract were based on
snp conference or the referendum and if
you look at the timeline there's
certainly in my view um not just serial
incompetence which is what i used to
think it was but actually an abusive
power and it is a disgraceful scandal
and
nobody is shedding light on it and we
need to understand the truth of what
went on james can you talk a bit about
nicola sturgeon's office which you and
michael mentioned in the piece how it
works and why you think it differs from
number 10 i mean is it really any more
secretive than what's happening in
whitehall
well i think in whitehall you certainly
have a degree to which is based on a
balance of power you know you have the
treasury you have the foreign office you
have a number of different whitehall
departments competing and some might say
that kind of competition does produce at
least a degree of accountability whereby
you know you have a number of different
ministers you can hold that prime
minister to account you know the prime
minister here for instance london
doesn't even have a department of his
own whereas in scotland if you talk to
civil servants people involved in the
government there i mean nicolas sturgeon
sort of looms like a zeppelin over the
whole thing um very even sort of minor
decisions get signed off by the first
minister which is why some people find
it hard to believe that in the ferguson
shipyard um she wasn't involved in
signing off any of it and that's why
you've seen a lot of the briefings going
on and a lot of the kind of spin that's
happened um because of what's happened
and what i think is the most important
kate is that the scottish government was
set up and the scottish parliament was
set up in 1999 and there was a real hope
and expectation about it here was a
chance for scotland and hollywood to do
much better than westminster and the sad
thing is that nicolas sturgeon a woman
who was elected in 2014 as first
minister to be the most quote accessible
first minister ever hasn't lived up to
that expectation and promise and that
kind of self-renewal that was hoped for
with the s p
when she was named first minister after
alexander left hasn't really taken place
and so i think the difference between
the aspiration and reality or the
rhetoric and reality is what is most
damning about what's going on in
scotland jackie james writes about
sturgeon's latest idea as part of a
pandemic law the scottish government
would be able to modify or amend any act
of parliament without a vote
what do you make of those plans are they
a non-starter in hollywood
i mean frankly i find them quite
extraordinary
it is astonishing what's being described
as sweeping henry viii powers
that the scottish government is seeking
will enable them without scrutiny
without approval of the scottish
parliament to simply change existing
primary legislation in whatever way they
wish now i think that frankly is just a
power grab too far um if you look at the
consultation civic scotland is opposed
to this in fact i think 80 if not 90
percent of the respondents said that
this just went too far um and was not
appropriate unfortunately the snp now
have a majority in the parliament
alongside their partners the greens and
so this will go through
unless we can make sufficient noise to
stop it from happening but it is quite
extraordinary that they now disregard
the parliament completely even during
the pandemic whilst it is appropriate to
give people emergency powers and the
parliament was able to do that quite
quickly and the reality is when it comes
to lane regulations they lay them and
only seek parliamentary approval after
the event that's not a smart way of
doing it if you want to take everybody
with you but as you say jackie the snp
has their majority you can make a lot of
noise but realistically is there much
more that you could do to stop them
well i think and what we've sought to do
is when you find that the government
isn't listening then actually making
common calls with civic scotland with
the experts and the professionals
whether it's in academia or in business
actually bears fruit because if the
entire country is saying this is not the
way to do things um then i do think any
government including nicolas sturgeon's
government really need to sit up and
listen um but but i live in hope that
that might happen but at the moment what
we're seeing is spin and assertion over
evidence and scrutiny and it's really
depressing because devolution could be
so much better than this james you and
michael write that there are structural
problems in the scottish parliament too
you write about the warnings that snps
were given during the alex salmon trial
for example
yes i mean i think that jackie touched
on an important point which is that you
know as long as you can the the one big
thing with the scottish electoral system
was that no people thought that no one
ever get a majority but once you've got
that effectively there aren't many
checks or balances you know compared to
westminster where you've got for
instance the house of lords we've got a
much more dynamic political culture in
terms of you know back benches you know
conservative mps holding a conservative
government to account all the same with
labour uh the dangerous you have those
kind of things um with the s p up in
scotland um and i think that the danger
is that uh with some of the alexander
stuff what went on was frankly um a very
dangerous mix of a separation of powers
being blurred um and
frankly the mechanism in scotland were
shown to be lacking and the question is
that now we have as jackie says an s p
green uh pro-independence governments
are just about propped up
will we see any of those failures being
addressed and typically what's happened
in scotland over the last 15 years is
that failures or institutions which are
shown to be wanting have not been
rectified have not had any kind of sort
of minor political constitutional reform
and so it's the institutions that have
been found wanting and the danger is
that there seems to be no impetus from
the governing parties to rectify that
anytime soon
james you you say in your piece that the
boundaries between the party and the
state up in scotland have in some cases
become indistinguishable you mentioned
the shipyard are there other cases
yes certainly is and i think that a
number of civil servants
up in scotland um you know most recently
leslie evans who was the permanent
secretary of the scottish government
until she recently left earlier this
year
have close connections to um the party
and the danger is of course is that if
you have a nationalist party in
government the tendency is to see that
party as the party of government and the
only legitimate voice in scotland and i
think that jackie and a number of other
sort of politicians take a different
view on that have had those voices
attempting to be shut down and i don't
think that's particularly healthy or
productive for scots so at the end that
they
have to live with a result of policies
that politicians put through
jackie last question to you you said in
february last year during the fall out
between nicola sturgeon and alex salmond
that quote there's something rotten at
the core of the smp and it is poisoning
our democratic institutions and quote
now as somebody who works inside
scotland's political system every day
have you noticed any changes have things
become better since last february
no in fact they've become worse
i think the scottish government is less
accountable more centralizing much more
secretive you know i i lived through the
salmon inquiry and i have to say the
level of obstruction from the scottish
government was absolutely legendary you
know we were given um papers only after
we sought them um doggedly for months
and months what we were given was by and
large redacted i mean i recall a
document of 22 pages where 20 pages were
actually snow white because everything
had been redacted
and they just simply refused to hand
over information i mean they didn't just
do it to a parliamentary committee they
did it in the courts as well and judges
had to order the government to hand over
information but you know one example i
would give you just recently um is where
the permanent secretary who is retiring
was asked to appear before the finance
and public administration committee of
the parliament you would think it was an
opportunity for her to talk about her
achievements she refused to attend a
serving senior civil servant simply
refused to attend the committee um and
she wasn't held to account by the
scottish government um and therefore she
was clearly too busy just
preparing for her retirement i find that
scandalous that the highest civil
servant in scotland is not instructed by
ministers to attend a parliamentary
committee jackie and james thanks for
joining me
a recent poll from conservative homes
saw boris johnson's ratings increased by
15 points katie balls writes in this
week's magazine about the new team that
has taken charge in number 10 putting
tory mps at the center of the operation
are they behind johnson's rise in
popularity katie joins me now
katie thanks for joining spectator tv in
your column for the magazine this week
you talk about the new face of number 10
who are the players
well i think the the biggest group of
players is actually just the
parliamentary party there's very much a
sense of
mps taking back control i've had several
incarnations of downing street under
boris johnson the first was dominic
cummings and the vote leave group and
that was very much taking back control
um centralizing power and having little
i think
regard for mps i think they are often
viewed as a nuisance partly because i
think if you thought back to the eu
referendum campaign the vote leave team
really felt as though part of the way
they won that referendum was not
listening to the advice of some tory
grandes and actually charting a new
course and that carried through to
downing street and created issues then
you had dan rosenfield he was the latest
chief of staff and dan rosenfield was a
former treasury civil servant and while
i think had a much more concilitary tone
of mps ultimately suffered the same
issue as dominic cummings in the sense
that tory mps did not really believe he
was a party member or a party person and
also lacked um in the case of dan
rosenfield some political noose
we now have a situation where the new
chief of staff in the wake of party gate
is steve barkley he is a tory mp and
this is a theme you also have the head
of policy andrew griffith is a tory mp
and more generally we're seeing this new
team which includes david canzini um a
former tory party figure um in terms of
strategy and coming in and uh guter
harry from boston city halls days and
there is a big effort underway to almost
to rebuild ties with the parliamentary
party and also the tory grass roots and
we're seeing that in various ways
and katie in your piece you explained
that there are some benefits to bringing
the mps back into the folds but we're
also starting to see the different
factions turn on each other as they feel
like they might have a bit more power
yes and i think what we're seeing is
ultimately there's there's a big effort
to listen more to mps so for example
there are two meetings a week uh with
tory mps just on policy with the various
constituencies trying to find out what
they want but also obviously hearing
what number 10 plans to do um there's
also a political meeting and every week
which is trying to avoid some of those
self-forced errors such as the owen
patterson tobacco um where the chief
whip will be there along with the party
chairman and they'll meet with number 10
which again gives you the mood of the
parliamentary party and special advisers
have also also told a recent meeting by
david canzini and i have linton crosby
they all needed to join the tory party
well raise your hand if you're if you
are a member and those who didn't raise
their hand for instructed that you know
what they need to do to fill in forms
and remedy that but i think there is
obviously an issue in the sense that
tory party is so large now um if you
look at the success of the 2019 election
victory um the majority of 80 yes should
mean on paper they can do a lot of
things but also means you have a lot of
different views and on any single issue
not everyone agrees i think the general
direction of this new team apart from
necessity and but also in terms of what
please the highest number of tory mps um
and and the base is to have more
conservative principles that's what the
new policy chief has told mps and
there's been i think i moved to the
right if you look at various decisions
recently such as the announcement they
plan to privatize channel 4 i can look
at some of the rhetoric on trans issues
and but for every single one of those
issues you are going to see a backlash
on the left of the party particularly
the one nation group i think the
question is when you are seeing these
potential rebellions um coming up is
that going to is that something that
will still allow boris johnson to get
his way and push for his agenda or could
they miscalculate and actually the
rebellion becomes so big that their
plans actually stopped in their tracks
katie you just mentioned there the
selling off of channel 4 which has been
in the news this week
it seems like a return to operation red
meat which we were talking about a few
months ago um an effort to appeal to the
base uh to the grassroots of the tory
party um and you know it wasn't it
wasn't said explicitly but frankly to
save the prime minister he was going
through some tough times with partygate
are these just recycled ideas we're
seeing from the new players in number 10
or is there something new a foot
so i think what's interesting on
operation red meat was that was a effort
immediately um
after boris johnson i think was in the
most trouble on partygate but actually
some of his old team who've now left dan
rosenfield the then director of
communications jack doyle have now left
but there was an effort there when it
was uh talk of freezing the bbc license
fee and there was and ending cover
restrictions i think the new team um are
not using the phrase operation redmi i
think they think it suggests uh two
limited policies not policies for
everyone um but it is in that same
direction of trying to uh move to the
right but i think uh when you're looking
at who they think they can win by doing
this there isn't there is more in the
sense that for example um we're
expecting planning reforms to be uh
ditched or
heavily diluted in the queen's speech
next month and there was plans for
radical planning
and that is going to please mps in the
south rather than just red wall mps so i
think it's a bit more
wide-ranging than some of the initial
things which i think were viewed as
almost you know greatest hits for
immediate effect
lastly katie it's been a tough week for
chancellor rishi sumac he has been
falling in several polls and there's
news today
about his wife's tax status tell us
what's been happening and what it means
for the chancellor
so i think we've seen wish you see next
personal approving ratings slowly
dropping um you know in recent months
and in a way that was inevitable he
ended last year as the most popular
politician in the country um he was
spending a lot of money for the first uh
you know
of his time as chancellor and and as
time goes on i think it was always the
case it was going to dip with the spring
statement that's been very sudden you
have a yougov poll this week which
suggests that he is now behind kirstama
and kirsten is also in the negative so
now all politicians in terms of the main
ones are in the negative so it's not
quite something i think to write home
back for the labour leader um but and
there was also a corner home cabinet
leaked table which is by tory members
and richard cena has dropped to the
bottom three boris jones has moved up so
clearly there is the tide is turning to
a degree
what is interesting is as the moon music
around richie's scenic changes and
people are finding more issues with him
i think uh things that in the past
haven't become live political issues
just like labour trying such as such as
risky cena's wealth and now are being
weaponized once again so we saw a story
this week about rishi soon like um
donating um over a hundred thousand
pounds i think we think over several
years within the details to um his the
private school he attended
and
that was uh you know taking my labor to
say well he couldn't find money for the
catch-up fund but he could find money
for this now this is his own private
money the labour attack land was almost
suggesting he should privately pay for
the you know kevin collins at the time
in his multi-billion pound deal so i
think that
had limited success but you can see the
narrative i think the issue right now
with the story over richie's wife and
the non-dom status is we're still uh
trying to find out the specific details
of this but um as it has been reported
um because uh she said its wife is
indian she does not have dual
citizenship and it means that she has
been paying uh on her foreign earnings
from the family company that she owns a
very small share in but is still a
high worth share either could the um
how much that company is worth and she
is paying attacks in india on that and i
think that clearly i think just having
the word non-dharmic you look at how
you think about the lord ashcroft pier
and rao back in the day is problematic
for a chance there at a time when
they're raising taxes um but i think
with this one we're just gonna have to
see what more comes out and how that
explanation um you know pans and stacks
up i think it was always acknowledged
that rishi sunap was going to hit a
tough patch it was understood that
handing out billions upon billions of
pounds hundreds of billions of pounds uh
to people at home to pay their wages to
businesses to give them limbs to get
through uh the pandemic was going to be
quite good time for the chancellor
personally um and his popularity ratings
and then having to tighten that having
to have the honest conversation with the
public about what that all really cost
was going to be a more difficult time
and yet there still seems to be some
element of surprise every time that
sunac falls in the polls do you think
that this was always inevitable and
there's an understanding that it was or
are things going especially bad at the
moment
i think he was always going to become
more unpopular over time particularly
because of you as you say the trajectory
of spending lots of money and paying
people's salaries um to suddenly saying
we're raising taxes and it's gonna be
tough cost of living and we can't do
everything to help you that is tricky i
think what is making it a bit worse
right now though is obviously i think
just personal uh disclosures stories
about his wife's potential tax affairs
and i think that's clearly a subject
that makes rishi like very uncomfortable
he um gave an interview and recently
saying you know it's not fair game to
come after my wife and i think what
we're seeing now is how does he handle
this level of scrutiny and pressure i
think that in some interviews he has
seemed um quite irritated by it and
therefore i think
what will help rishi sunaka's full
transparency and a calm approach and
what will make it worse is if
if it starts to look bad tempered and i
think when it comes to tax affairs you
can obviously say your wife's a private
individual that's what we hear from the
treasury and so she shouldn't expect
help to the same standards as a
politician i think most people would
accept that but i think there's still
some legitimate questions that should be
answered
katie thanks for joining me
and finally paul wood writes in this
week's magazine about the kolonewski
battalion a small group of volunteers
from belarus who are fighting for
ukraine against russia what does this
say about the position of belarusian
dictator alexander lukashenko could a
larger resistance from inside the
country threaten his regime paul joins
me now
paul thanks for joining spectator tv in
your piece for the magazine this week
you talk about the small group of
belarusian volunteer soldiers who are on
the front line of what's happening in
ukraine tell us about them
well it is a small number i think
symbolically important
belarusian volunteers have been fighting
in ukraine since 2014 they were part of
the azov battalion which has attracted
its own controversies allegedly for some
of the neo-fascist leaning of some of
its members
but these belarusian volunteers have
been there since 2014
and then they were formally incorporated
into the ukrainian armed forces two
weeks ago this is something the
ukrainians have been doing in order to
give all the foreign volunteers fighting
for them the protection of the geneva
conventions there are thousands of
foreigners arriving in ukraine
people from europe britain's americans
all of them are made to sign a contract
joining the ukrainian army and now the
belarusian volunteers are formerly part
of ukraine's armed forces they still
fly the red and white flag which is the
pre-soviet belarusian flag
which nationalists in belarus have taken
as their symbol
and they operate as a self-contained
unit
alongside other volunteers such as i
believe from georgia
and there probably are only a few
hundred of them i'm told there are four
separate units the main one being
involved in the defense of kiev uh and
possibly only a couple of hundred there
but it is of enormous symbolic
importance that this neighboring country
and a country whose president alexander
lukashenko
is allied with the kremlin and although
has been very cautious about getting
involved in the war is supposedly one of
vladimir putin's allies
and
there are enormous hopes pinned um that
the belarusian opposition have pinned on
the fighters
in belarus um
not for what will happen in ukraine but
they are hoping that um
people will look from belarus into
ukraine
see the defiance of vladimir putin and
that is a message which will travel all
the way back to minsk we'll see
we'll come back to how what's happening
in ukraine could have an impact on
belarus but first given that many of
these volunteers were arrested in the
2020-2021
belarusian protests against their own
dictator do they have much military
experience to be fighting on the front
line of this war
well as i say some of them have been
there since 2014 and presumably they
have military experience
um and
the ones who've been there for the past
month are certainly getting military
experience
a lot of those fighting on the ukrainian
side don't have much experience but
morale is the great determining factor
in war the russians are certainly better
equipped uh probably more numerous in
terms of the organized forces they can
command but they have no morale and
we've seen
demoralized russian troops uh retreating
in in a chaotic fashion often not very
well supplied being beaten back by
ukrainian volunteers belarusian
volunteers foreign volunteers with
ancient weapons but the will to fight i
think that makes the difference it's
certainly making the difference
now with the ukrainians pushing the
russians back indeed up the road to
belarus and
perhaps more important than the military
contribution of these belarusian
volunteers
is
what has been taking place in belarus
itself
we have had reports of railway lines
sabotaged
stopping the movement of troops into
belarus stopping the movement of spare
parts and fuel there have been so-called
cyber partisan attacks shutting down
the belarusian cyber infrastructure
which the russians again may be using
all of that i think might be more
important because the russians
use belarus as a staging area on their
way into ukraine they will presumably
need to use it as a rear safe area to
patch up their wounds and regroup if
they're going to counter-attack and
a few hundred volunteers i think stand
for a much larger commitment by the
belarusian public
against this war and that is why you're
seeing these acts of sabotage
it's the crucial questions will those
acts of sabotage be enough to undermine
the russian war machine
and do you think that it's this small
battalion in particular that's putting
the pressure on putin's relationship
with lukashenko
one of a number of things i think
far more significant
would be the attitude of the belarusian
army now a month ago there were a lot of
confident predictions that president
lukashenko would order the belarusian
army into action alongside russian
forces there are only 45 000 of them and
i spoke to one belarusian journalist you
thought
the actual number of combat troops they
could field would be only 10 000 not
enough to make a huge difference on the
battlefield but helpful enough to
vladimir putin's war effort but that
never happened and i think it didn't
happen um because of the fears that
president lukashenko might reasonably
have that the army would refuse to carry
out orders either it would go through a
show of crossing the border and carrying
out some what would describe to me as
fake attacks while staying as far away
from the ukrainian forces as possible
all they could outright mutilate and
certainly those are the hopes of the
belarusian opposition if orders were
given by president lukashenko cross the
border south into ukraine that the army
would mutilate so the idea that these
belarusian volunteers
two three four hundred of them however
they are would turn around and march
back to mints to overthrow president
lukashenko i think that is fanciful
but a far bigger risk and a far more
realistic risk for him is that he is
pushed into blackmailed into joining the
war by president putin his own army
mutinies and that is the signal for a
more generalized uprising against him
if lukashenko doesn't order his army to
go and help the russians in ukraine is
he safe from mutiny or is there still a
chance that his own army might rebel
against him or that they might decide to
go and join the small battalion and grow
it in size
i think unlikely the army the regular
army would go and join the volunteers uh
they probably just sit on their hands um
it's a black hole we don't know what
they're thinking what they're saying
the belarusian opposition is already
calling itself the government in exile
and is confidently predicting that the
war in ukraine will somehow end in what
they call a free belarus
that's the job of oppositions to sound
confident like that i must admit that i
spoke to
some democracy activists and they'd had
a pretty tough time one of them had just
got out of prison she was a grandmother
in her 60s she'd been held with no
charge against for the better part of
the year arrested in front of her family
and as soon as she was released she fled
to poland she was a little bit more
pessimistic she thought the sequence of
events would be a defeat in ukraine for
vladimir putin leading to a palace coup
in the kremlin and once putin is gone
that is one of the main pillars of
support that alexander lukashenko has
the other being of course the security
forces and the police but you would
imagine they would lose confidence
looking at um a palace coup in the
kremlin
so
opinions vary about this but i think
underlying this
is the fact that probably most fellow
missions pose the war certainly oppose
getting into the war
on the side of russia even president
lukashenko's own supporters so he has to
be very very careful these are very
testing times for him although i have to
say that the democracy activists i
suspect who nicknamed him the cockroach
he always seems to survive whatever
happens to him
uh i want to go back to the point you
are making at the start of this about
the wider objectives of this small
battalion it does seem like there is a
bigger agenda here you say in your piece
for the magazine that their motto is
first ukraine than belarus
well that's the motto
they're nationalists they don't want to
be part of a russian empire as they
would see it
so yes of course once the ukrainian war
is won as they hope they will return to
belarus uh i think a few hundred
volunteers are not going to make the
difference
uh on their own but taken together with
street protests we've seen remarkably
brave street protests in belarus against
the war against president lukashenko
possibly more than a thousand arrests
the opposition say there are now more
than a thousand political prisoners
being held in belarus
so if if the tide of events turns in
ukraine turns in russia in moscow as
well you can see it happening to
president mukashenko too
he is
treading a very difficult and narrow
path between pressure from the kremlin
and making his own people so unhappy
that they overthrow him
uh paul last question to you what are
the stakes for the belarusians fighting
in ukraine and for ukraine what might
happen to them when they return to
belarus
well i don't imagine they'll return to
belarus for president lukashenko is in
power they'd be arrested
it's probably too early to talk about
that first they have to win the war in
ukraine look in another sense the stakes
for them are mistakes for everybody
which is
ultimately and most disastrously this
could end in a nuclear exchange beyond
ukraine's borders that's because the
kremlin is very very deliberately
playing the nuclear card reminding the
world that they have these weapons
adopting almost the mirror image of the
strategic ambiguity that nato had in the
1980s when nato said well maybe we'll
use nuclear weapons maybe we won't if we
face a conventional threat
this is what vladimir putin is saying to
the world and i spoke to for instance
fiona hill who used to be on the
national security council official there
in charge of russia
she and other experts are saying look it
is not impossible that vladimir putin
uses nuclear weapons and if he does that
it is um possible that it would be a
weapon a tactical nuke fired from
belarusian soil the belarusian president
has forced through changes to the
constitution ending belarus's
nuclear-free status that's another move
i'm sure which is deeply unpopular in
his country and done at the behest of
the kremlin so ultimately the stakes for
everybody are does this turn into a
nuclear war for belarus and for
everybody else
paul thanks for joining spectator tv
and that's it for this week once again
don't forget to subscribe to the
spectators youtube channel just click
the subscribe button at the bottom of
this video and tap the bell icon to make
sure you never miss an episode thanks
for watching and do join us again next
week
[Music]
you